نبدا هذه النشره باخر تطورات سد النهضه
ففي الوقت الذي تقول فيه اثيوبيا انها
انهت ما يقارب تسعين في المئه من اعمال سد
النهضه تستعد اديس ابابا لعمليه التعبئه
الرابعه المتوقعه شهرين مايو ويونيو
المقبلين في هذا الصدد قال المتحدث باسم
الخارجيه
ثلاثيه مع مصر والسودان تعود بالفائده على
الجميع بشان حل الخلاف حول السد وفي
المقابل شدد المتحدث الاثيوبي على ان
بلاده لا تحتاج الى اذن من احد
لتعبئه سد النهضه مؤكدا التزامات بحل
القضيه داخل البيت الافريقي
شرحنا من قبل بان اثيوبيا لا تحتاج الى
اذن لاجراء التعبئه وسد النهضه لن يلحق
الضرر بمصر والسودان وهم يعرفون ذلك
تزامنا مع اي تعبئه تشن علينا حمله لتشويه
صورتنا واظهارنا باننا دوله لا تحترم
القوانين الدوليه وهذه طريقه لصرف الانظار
عن الاوضاع السياسيه الداخليه لديهم
اثيوبيا ملتزمه بحل القضيه داخل البيت
الافريقي
في المقابل قال وزير الري المصريه هاني
سويلم ان مصر تواصل المفاوضات والمناقشات
مع اثيوبيا بشان سد النهضه وتقديم عدد من
المقترحات لها والحلول لتوفير الطاقه
واضاف ان سد النهضه يمثل ضغطا على موارد
المياه المصريه لاسيما وان حجم الفيضانات
يؤثر بشكل مباشر على كميه المياه الوارده
سواء مرتفعه او منخفضه وقال ان هناك
محاولات لايجاد سبل للتعاون ما تزال قائمه
معنى الان من اديس ابابا مراسل الجزيره
حسن رزاق للوقوف والقراءه في تصريحات
المتحدث باسم الخارجيه الاثيوبيه حسنا
بالفعل ازدهار يمكن تلخيص تصريحات الم
المتحدث باسم الخارجيه الاثيوبيه في
نقطتين النقطه الاولى حول المفاوضات اشار
ان بلاده متمسكه باستعاده المفاوضات
الثلاثيه بين مصر والسودان واثيوبيا داخل
البيت الافريقي بما يعم بالفائده على
الجميع طبعا ازدهار المفاوضات هي معلقه
منذ ابريل عام 2021 وكانت اخر مفاوضات
ثلاثيه عقدت في كريشاسه عاصمه الكونغو
لكنها لم تحرز اي نتائج ومنذ تلك الفتره
المفاوضات الثلاثيه المعلقه حدثت اختراقات
بين اثيوبيا والسودان تحديدا حيث كان زار
عبد الفتاح البرهان اثيوبيا وتم تشكيل
لجنه بين اثيوبيا والسودان لحل مشكله سد
النهضه لكن المشكله بين مصر وبين اثيوبيا
لا زالت معلقه وبالتالي اليوم اكد من
المفاوضات الثلاثيه هي هدف كبير لاثيوبيا
تحت البيت الافريقي النقطه ازدهار فيما
يتعلق بالملا اشار ان الملا الرابع
والمقرر في الفتره القادمه في موسم
الامطار لن تحتاج اثيوبيا من خلال الى اذن
من دولتين مصر والسودان باعتبار ان الاذن
بحسب مواقف سابقه ان الاذن تم اخذه في من
ضمن اتفاقيه اعلام المبادئ الموقعه بين
اثيوبيا ومصر السودان في عام 2015 اثيوبيا
فقط تخطر دولتين المصاب بان الملء قد بدا
وبالتالي هذا الملء لا يحتاج الى اذن
وايضا فيما يتعلق بالضرر اشار ان التعبئات
الثلاثه السابقه لم تحدث ضررا لمصر
والسودان ولم تثبت حتى الان اي دراسات او
اي جهات علميه انه احدثت ضررا لمصر
والسودان وبالتالي عمليات التشويه ما
وصفها ويرفض ما وصف عمليه التشويه واظهار
اثيوبينا دوله خارجه عن القانون الدولي
هذا هو ملخص هذا هو ملخص ما تحدث بمجلس في
المؤتمر الصحفي اكد موقف بلادي ان
المفاوضات الثلاثيه تحت رعايه الاتحاد
الافريقي هي هدف اثيوبيا شكرا جزيلا لك من
ابا مراسل الجزيره حسن رزاق سنبقى في ذات
الملف معنى لان القاهره الاستاذ عطيه
عيسوي الخبير في الشؤون الافريقيه نرحب بك
استاذ عطيه في تقديرك ما هي التداعيات
المحتمله لاصرار اثيوبيا على التعبئه
الرابعه لسد النهضه وانها تقول انها لا
تحتاج اذنا من احد من اجل هذه التعبئه
اهلا وسهلا
التداعيات طبعا كثيره
اذا استمرت اثيوبيا في نهجها الحالي ولم
تراعي مصالح وحقوق مصر والسودان في مياه
النيل يعني ابسط ما في الامر انه اذا
استمر اسلوب اسلوبيا الحالي
في الملء والتشغيل فسوف يؤدي ذلك عند حدوث
جفاف حاله جفاف ممتد او مطول سوف تفقد مصر
15% من اراضيها الزراعيه وسوف تتضاع
والدتها الغذائيه وسوف يفقد حوالي واحد
وواحد واحد واحد من عشره مليون
انسان
فرص العمل في الزراعه
والنشاطات المرتبطه بها مصر لم تنتظر في
اعتقادي حتى يحدث ذلك
لم يتم استئناف المفاوضات بنيه خالصه
وتسمح اثيوبيا للخبراء على الاقل ان لم
تسمح للوصفاء بان
يستانفوا المقاوضات ويتدخلوا لحل الخلافات
وتقديم المقترحات اعتقد ان اي مفاوضات تحت
رئاسه الاتحاد الافريقي لان
اثيوبيا تستند في موقفها اثيوبيا تستند في
موقفها كما تقول بدراسات لخبراء تقول بانه
لا ضرر على السودان ومصر بعد التعبئه
الثانيه
والثالثه ما الذي تم رصده مصريا فيما
يتعلق بالتعبئتين الثانيه والثالثه من
اضرار
يعني فيما يتعلق بالدراسات نحن من حقنا ان
نعترض على نتائج الدراسات الاثيوبيه وانما
نثق في الدراسات الدوليه المحايده هذه
الدراسات رفضتها اثيوبيا من قبل بعد ان تم
الاتفاق عليها مع مكتب فرنسي واعتقد مكتب
بلجيكي هذه الدراسات كان من المفروض ان
وتم دفع تكاليف هذه الدراسات هذه الدراسات
كان من المفروض ان تحدد نواقص النواقص
التي
وردت في الدراسات الاثيوبيه وان
تقترح علاجا لها اثيوبيا رفضت استكمال هذه
الدراسات وبالتالي لا نستطيع ان نقول ان
الدراسات الاثيوبيه موثوق بها وانها تؤكد
انه لا ضرر كيف لا ضرر واثيوبيا تصر على
اولا
عدم استكمال الدراسات ثانيا عدم
بالتدخل رغم لحل الخلافات رغم ان اتفاقيه
المبادئ التي تستند اليها في عام 2015 تنص
على اللجوء الى طرف ثالث بمعنى وسيط بشكل
غير مباشر اذا لم يتم الاتفاق من خلال
المفاوضات او المشاورات ايضا
رفضت كل المقترحات المصريه ومنها اقتراح
ينص على ان يتم الملء والتشغيل
بما يضمن لاثيوبيا انتاج 80% من الطاقه
الكهربائيه للسد دون
الاضرار بمصالح وحقوق مصر والسودان
كيميائيه كل هذه الامور رفع اثيوبيا اذا
هي الذي تعيق المفاوضات شكرا وهي التي ادت
الى او تسببت في عدم وصولها الى اتفاق حتى
الان من القاهره عطيه عيساويه الخبير في
الشؤون الافريقيه شكرا جزيلا لك